[Musique]
bonjour la légende raconte que cette
découverte a eu lieu il ya de nombreux
siècles avant notre ère en grèce antique
et c'était un berger nommé madness qui
se balader sur la plage avec des
sandales et à un moment donné on s'est
rendu compte que ces sandales elle est
collée au sol par une sorte de colle
imaginaire alors il a commencé à creuser
pour comprendre d'où venait cette cette
colle virtuel qui n'est qu'il ne voyait
pas et il est tombé sur cette pierre
cette pierre on l'appelle de la
magnétite et c'était la première
découverte de ce qu'on appelle un
élément naturel c'est-à-dire une pierre
qui est capable d'attirer les métaux et
à cette époque là la découverte de
mayonnaise n'avait absolument aucune
utilité
une pierre qui colle au clou de sa
sandale ça servait absolument rien et on
lui a donné quelques pouvoirs mystiques
évidemment mais ça n'avait pas beaucoup
plus usage jusqu'à ce que de nombreux et
nombreux nombreux siècles plus tard
quelques siècles après le début de notre
ère en chine on invente la boussole on
avait repris la magnétite on l'avait
formé sous forme d'aiguillé puis posé
sur un bol d'eau et ça pouvait indiquer
le nord au début on lui attribue et on
l'a utilisé pour la divination
mais ça va vite c'est vite venu
révolutionné le monde de la navigation
ainsi que notre qu'un autre monde est
celui là ne savait pas encore mais aussi
l'apparence de nos frigos et donc ça en
fait c'était le début du magnétisme à
partir d'une pierre qui semblait
complètement inutile ça a un style ça
est émerveillé les gens et puis ils ont
été très curieux de savoir comment est
ce que ça fonctionne qu est-ce que c'est
le magnétisme
est-ce qu'on peut le reproduire est-ce
qu'on peut le contrôler est-ce que tout
peut devenir magnétique et donc à partir
de cette excitation intellectuelle de la
découverte de l'inconnu des générations
et des générations de personnes se sont
développées toutes les connaissances que
l'on a sur le magnétisme et aujourd'hui
grâce à eux notre monde serait vraiment
très différent si on avait pas le
magnétisme je suis sûr que vous vous le
savez mais en voici quelques exemples
aujourd'hui tous nos hauts parleurs les
micros un aimant dans leur membrane
vibrante tous les disques durs également
utilise des propriétés magnétiques mais
aussi les train à lévitation magnétique
les plaques à induction et la prochaine
c'est probablement l'invention la plus
importante mais de corps ramassés les
boules de pétanque mais aussi toutes les
bandes magnétiques des cartes bancaires
tous les moteurs électriques qui se base
aussi sur du magnétisme de l'induction
en particulier dans les déchetteries
pour déplacer des éléments lourds
métallique et il y en a une liste très
très longue mais mon application
préférée à moi du magnétisme mon petit
mon petit chouchou à moi c'est l'irm irm
ça veut dire imagerie par résonance
magnétique et c'est un scanner d'hôpital
que vous connaissez peut-être si jamais
vous avez déjà fait un examen vous savez
qu'on vous demande d'enlever tous vos
bijoux et une des raisons à ça c'est pas
la seule mais une des raisons c'est
parce que l'irm en fait c'est un énorme
et man entre autres choses et on utilise
des propriétés magnétiques de notre
corps pour être capable d'imagés
l'intérieur du corps humain et donc
finalement à partir de cette pierre qui
était complètement inutile qu'ils
n'avaient aucun intérêt et de toute la
curiosité des personnes qui s'y sont
intéressés qu'ils n'avaient absolument
aucun but pratique qui avait aucune
envie de chercher une utilité à
comprendre le magnétisme
mais c'est devenu utile par la suite et
ça nous a donné de nombreuses inventions
et c'est de ça dont je voudrais vous
parler aujourd'hui de l'utilité des
recherches qui semblent inutiles alors
avec l'exemple que je viens de vous
donner
on s'entend que c'est assez facile j'ai
pris un champ tellement vaste le
magnétisme
c'est sûr qu'on allait trouver quelque
chose qu'on avait trouvé un exemple de
l'utilité au magnétisme et on pourrait
se dire que finalement des recherches
inutiles
il y en a plein c'est juste que comme
elle était inutile à sont tombés dans
l'oubli
ce serait assez logique et bien je vous
donne un autre exemple qui est tiré de
mes propres recherches
aucun exemple de recherches inutiles
parce qu'avant de faire ce que je fais
aujourd'hui je faisais la recherche
académique
alors aujourd'hui j'en fais plus
aujourd'hui je fais de la vulgarisation
scientifique comme avec vous en ce
moment où sur ma chaîne youtube syllabus
est un de mes sujets qui m'intéressent
beaucoup c'est de parler de plein de
sujets qui semblent inutiles encore une
fois comme le sont que fait le café
quand on tape dessus avec une cuillère
qui évolue dans le temps là
physique des poils mouillé pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a la fourrure autour des
capuches pourquoi est ce que les ourlets
rubik
ou encore pourquoi les vertus en face
ils ne sont pas faciles et tous ces
sujets là tous se base sur des
recherches scientifiques académiques
sérieuses donc peut-être que ma ma
propension à aimer les ce qui semble
inutile
encore une fois c'est parce que j'ai
donc moi aussi produit mon lot de
recherches inutiles
je vais donc vous parler du projet
maurice alors pour vous donner un petit
peu de contexte c'était dans un
laboratoire laboratoire de nanorobotique
je venais juste d'arriver c'était il ya
dix ans et dans ce laboratoire comme
dans la grande majorité des laboratoires
la science est un peu tentaculaire dans
le sens où on a un thème principal
et puis ce thème se décline sous la
forme de plein de petits projets qui
répondent à ce thème là donc nous notre
thème à nous c'était de guider
magnétiquement des robots dans le corps
humain
alors ce qu'on appelle robot c'est faut
pas s'imaginer un humanoïde ça peut être
quelque chose de très simple un robot
c'est juste quelque chose de tangible
que l'on peut diriger c'est ça un robot
pour nous sans que ça peut être très
simple évident et avec ça c'est que si
on arrive à avoir un robot qu'on peut
amener où on veut dans le corps humain
mais y'a plus qu'à lui attacher un sac à
dos de médicaments et puis on va pouvoir
ali ben guérir des tumeurs des cancers à
des endroits très localisés ça c'est
toute l'idée du laboratoire où je
travaillais et ça se décliner en plein
de projets différents donc un des
projets c'était le 7e le mien c'était
mon principal le projet cathéter donc
les cathéters cd long tube de plastique
qu'on met dans les vaisseaux sanguins
mais mon projet s'était développé un
petit embout qui permettait de contrôler
l'embout du cathéter en trois dimensions
un autre projet projet particules
c'était des nanoparticules donc vraiment
minuscule qui avait à l'intérieur des du
magnétisme des particules magnétiques et
du médicament comme ça on pouvait amener
les particules dans d'un corps humain et
le dernier le projet back terril du
moins le dernier que je vous présente où
ce sont des bactéries donc elle qui ont
des flagelles donc leur permettre de se
déplacer tout seul puis on lui accrocher
encore une fois des médicaments pour les
déplacés donc voyez on a un thème
général mais ça se décline sous plein de
robots différents
et un jour ça faisait deux semaines de
six mois que j'étais d'un laboratoire -
directeur ne me convoque dans son bureau
là il commence à me parler et je
comprends que il veut ouvrir une
nouvelle tentacules à son projet à son
terme il veut il veut il veut faire
quelque chose de nouveau et il me donne
deux semaines pour le faire et ce qu'il
me dit c'est qu'il voudrait que je
conçoive un robot guider magnetic man
avec des cils moi non plus je sais pas
ce que ça veut dire
et comme j'étais à mes tout débuts en
cherche avais aucune idée de comment
conduire une expérience donc je me suis
on a fait ça avec le un post doctorants
du laboratoire bien plus expérimentés
que moi qui est depuis devenu professeur
d'université d'ailleurs et avec deux
semaines devant nous pour inventer ce
que sa lettre en robot avec des cils
conduire une expérience et publie un
article
on avait il fallait aller au plus simple
mais temps donc on est allés au plus
simple et notre robot à nous c'était une
simple billes de métal et notre
interprétation de ce que ça allait être
les cils ça a été une feuille de
plastique qu'on a collé à la bille de
métal et on a mis le tout dans un
aquarium parce que on a l'habitude de
travailler dans les vaisseaux sanguins
donc c'est a priori un milieu liquide
puis évidemment quand on met une bille
de métal dans un aquarium ça ça coule
donc on a résolu ce problème simplement
en rajoutant une billes de polystyrène
lorsque vous voyez ici c'est le fameux
le fameux robot mais vu de dessus vous
avez là là le cil qui est donc une
espèce de queue avec l'habit qui est
caché sous un petit morceau de
polystyrène est comme ça commençait
vraiment à ressembler à ressembler un
poisson on a dessiné deux petits yeux et
c'est d'ailleurs de là que vient le nom
du projet maurice parce que maurice a
fait référence à une publicité 10 à 15
20 en france pour un petit garçon qui
expliquait à ses parents que c'était son
poisson rouge maurice qui avait mangé
toutes les mousses au chocolat il disait
tu pousses le bouchon un peu trop loin à
maurice donc c'est si vous trouvez ça
ridicule vous avez raison cela dit c'est
assez courant quand on découvre une
nouvelle espèce en science de s'inspirer
de personnages réels ou de fiction vous
avez par exemple le auto5 lui ce batman
y donc % signale batman au niveau de la
queue ou le aller aux idées
et pour ses danses du ventre ou encore
le sponge format square penn 6% bob
l'eponge qui en anglais se dit cependant
bob square pence alors nous c'est pas
vraiment une nouvelle espèce a on avait
inventé un petit robot et moi nous
amuser c'était ça le principal donc on a
un robot ce robot faut arriver à le
déplacer parce que c'est toute l'idée là
c'est qu'il faut arriver à le déplacer
magnetic man nous le magnétisme c'était
on avait un irm donc l'appareil
d'imagerie dont je vous parlais et il
était juste à nous il y avait aucun
patient qui qui allaient dans l'irm est
donc avec dans laboratoire en avait pour
habitude avec les informaticiens de
recoder l'irm et de l'ajuster pour nos
besoins
il se trouve que les propriétés
magnétiques de l'ariège l'irm
nous on arrivait à appliquer une force
magnétique dans toutes les directions de
l'espace et donc c'était on pouvait
utiliser ça donc c'est ce qu'on a fait
avec nôtre notre petit poisson maurice
on le mettait dans l'ensemble vocal qui
ont appliqué une force magnétique dans
un sens grâce à l'irm donc sur le dévier
et puis après on appliquait une force
magnétique dans l'autre sens donc ça le
dvi à nouveau dans l'autre sens et petit
à petit on arrivait à faire nager notre
petit poisson et voici donc en chair et
en os ou plutôt en métal et en plastique
maurice donc ce que vous voyez là c'est
donc notre petit poisson qui est dans
son aquarium et l'aquarium lui-même est
à l'intérieur d'un irm et on utilise une
caméra pour voir ce qu'on voit en ce
moment non pas les propriétés d'imagerie
drm vraiment juste une caméra et c'est
une caméra très spéciale parce que on
peut pas mettre n'importe quelle caméra
dans un irm à cause justement du
magnétisme et d'où la qualité qui n'est
pas dans les standards d'aujourd'hui est
donc on avait notre petit poisson
fonctionnel imagé mais maintenant
fallait l'étudier fallait qu'est ce qui
marche le mieux comment est ce qu'on le
fait nager et c'est donc on a fait de
plein de petits maurice est certain
qu'ils nagent vite certains qui nagent
lentement on a changé la fréquence de du
magnétisme là à changer la longueur de
la queue on a changé le type etc
et puis au bout de deux semaines on a
enfin publié notre premier article
et puis le projet a continué pendant
quelques mois encore moi j'étais
retourné à mon projet principal
et puis ça s'est arrêté là tu es tout ça
c'est fini pour ainsi dire en queue de
poisson
si vous me permettez et en fait on avait
une preuve de concept dans le sens où on
avait réussi à faire nager quelque chose
on s'entend qui avait encore énormément
d'étapes pour arriver à le rendre
fonctionnel dans un corps humain mais ça
s'est arrêté là raison à sage l'ignorent
mais j'imagine que le laboratoire jugé
que les autres tentacules les autres
projets avait plus d'avenir ils ont
réalisé les ressources à d'autres
projets tout simplement avec une feinte
pareil est ce que maurice est ce que
projets mûrs maurice était utile alors
vous connaissez déjà mon point de vue là
dessus puisque je voulais dit au tout
début mais moi je pense que oui toutes
les recherches ont une utilité et on
peut en trouver plusieurs des utilités
la première qui est selon moi valide
pour vraiment absolument toutes les
recherches c'est une utilité qui est un
peu un direct quand on regarde
l'histoire des sciences
on se rend bien compte que on est
complètement aveugle on y va à tâtons
on n'a aucune idée de ce qu'est ce qui
va déboucher qu'est-ce qu'on peut
découvrir donc comme on ne peut pas
prédire ce qu'on veut ce qu'on peut
découvrir ben on essaye tout un tas de
tentatives et donc en essayant une voix
on découvre qu'elle ne fonctionne pas ou
qu'elle n'a pas d'avenir
mais c'est une information super
importante c'est super d'avoir un
résultat négatif parce que ça nous
permet de nous redirigés ailleurs
et à force de nous re dirigé ailleurs
ben on va bien trouver une méthode qui
fonctionne et donc ça fait partie
finalement du processus de la science et
toutes les tentatives font partie d'un
tout donc souvent on parle des dernières
recherches qui ont abouti mais on oublie
toutes les tentatives avant qu'ils ont
échoué mais qui font partie de ce
processus là et donc dans le laboratoire
aujourd'hui donc dix ans plus tard tous
les autres projets ont été arrêtés ou
mis en stand by et c'est uniquement le
projet bactéries qui qui qui fonctionne
encore parce que toutes les ressources
ont été alloués à ce projet là et les
les îles sont en train de faire des
essais si ça se trouve dans quelques
années ce projet là on le verra sur le
marché c'est tout c'est tout le mal que
je leur souhaite donc ça c'est une des
premières utilité de toutes les
recherches ça fait partie du processus
de sciences tous les autres projets ça
veut pas dire qu'ils n'étaient pas bien
mais étaient dans le processus de
développer le projet d'acte est la
deuxième utilité c'est une utilité qui
est potentiellement direct mais met
direct peut-être pas aujourd'hui parce
que nous on est enfermé dans une bulle
spatio-temporelle on n'a aucune idée on
peut pas prédire l'avenir donc dans la
mesure où on sait pas si une recherche
peut devenir utile
il serait complètement prétentieux de
notre part de jauger de l'utilité d'une
science donc il faut réserver notre
jugement est justement ne pas dire si
une recherche est utile ou pas puis il
ya un autre phénomène qui est non
seulement on ne peut pas voir l'avenir
mais en plus de nombreuses technologies
qui apparaissent le sont grâce à la
concordance de nombreuses recherches
si on prend l'exemple de l'irm mon petit
favori
l'irm c'est le résultat de travaux en
magnétisme supraconductivité en
mathématiques un thermique en
informatique un structure de l'atome et
j'en passe mais ça sauve pris
individuellement toutes ces avancées
l'avait pas forcément d'utilité pratico
pratique mais rassembler ensemble dans
l'irm
là c'est devenu particulièrement utile
et finalement le l'essence même de dire
que quelque chose est utile ou inutile
n'a pas forcément de sens et je préfère
cette appellation là qui est séparé les
sciences en sciences appliquées et
sciences pas encore appliquée qui est
une formulation de georges porter qui
est un chimiste nobélisé et j'apprécie
beaucoup cette formulation là ce que je
pense que vraiment toutes les recherches
ont une utilité ou en auront une un jour
puis une dernière utilité qui que j'aime
beaucoup qui ait une utilité plus
pédagogique - maurice aujourd'hui il me
permet d'être face à vous pour vous
parler de l'activité principale des
chercheurs qui est de chercher de
trouver de tenter des choses finalement
de tenter des choses tenter des choses
c'est ça le vrai travail d'un chercheur
et grâce à maurice et bien je peux vous
en parler parler et ça mais ça c'est
utile
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]